- Whatever you do, don't
be rude to the people
handling your food because you might find
a pubic hair in your burger.
(upbeat music)
- How do you get something for free?
B.Y.O.B. bring your own bug. (chuckles)
- Complain, first off, but you don't even
have to complain that much,
you don't even have to make a scene.
Open the package and
take one bite of the food
and then return it and
they can't take it back
over the counter most of the time,
so you're just gonna
get free food that way.
- Some of the managers
at some of the spots,
sometimes they have coupons that they have
in their back pocket and they give out
whenever they feel like
they're in good spirits.
So if you see a manager when
you walk into a spot, be nice.
- [Woman] What time is best to order food?
- The best time to order
food is right when they open.
- Breakfast, you wanna order
it as early as possible.
If you get breakfast towards
the end of the breakfast time,
you're getting the worst, oldest, stalest,
grossest eggs ever,
you're getting them nasty.
If you're gonna be buying
food for lunch or dinner,
you wanna do that outside of the rush hour
because the rush hour is
when we don't pay attention
to the quality of the food.
Do ice cream machines really break?
All the time.
They are the worst machines ever made.
They get jammed, nobody likes them.
We hate that you buy ice cream.
- Sometimes like we don't have people
who either don't know
how to use the machine.
Sometimes people are just
lazy and don't feel like
walking over to the
machine and they'll lie
and say it's broke.
- [Woman] Are you told to
fill cups with ice on purpose
or not fill up cartons
with fries to the top?
- We're gonna fill up a
lot of ice in that cup
because you're gonna get less soda.
If you're gonna go to a place,
go to one where you can get
your own soda out of the machine
because that's the only way
to cheat the system on that.
- For fries, if we
haven't made a new batch
and it's like the scraps
of the last batch,
we'll just try to get
what's last in there.
- We always, always, always
didn't fill them to the top.
We did that on purpose.
If we ever did it, we got in trouble.
Our boss did not like that.
- What are the consequences
if you put soda in a free water cup?
Diabetes? (chuckles)
- You get arrested immediately.
(siren wails)
No, I'm kidding.
They don't do anything at all.
Don't do the brown sodas because
then it doesn't look as conspicuous.
- If there's a manager standing by you,
maybe they might call
you out and you might get
a little shamed, a water cup shaming.
- Are the employees must wash hand sign
more of a reminder for you
or to make customers feel better?
It's for all of us.
We shouldn't have to remind you as adults
to wash your hands, but we all
should just wash our hands.
- They think that sign's
just gonna throw it out there
and make the customers
immediately think oh,
of course they're washing their
hands, they're so hygienic.
Yeah, that's not always the case.
- There are some people that
might not wash their hands
because they wear gloves and might just
put on gloves on top of their dirty hands
like oh, what do I need
to wash my hands for?
You idiot, you just put on
gloves with your dirty hands.
- So if you ever see
anybody handle your food,
make sure that they're wearing
gloves every single time.
I'm not gonna tell you why,
I'm just gonna say make
sure they're wearing gloves.
- Are names misleading?
Does fresh always mean fresh? (laughs)
I plead the fifth on that question.
- Names being misleading, yeah.
There's a lot of fake lines
that are put on those burgers
to think that they're
going through a flame,
they're not, there's no fire
that touches those things.
- Have you ever created your
own secret menu, what was it?
If you're lactose intolerant like me
and you don't want cheese
on your baked potato,
barbecue sauce is the way to go.
It's like a big, giant
barbecue potato chip.
- I would always get the
ice cream concoctions.
I would throw salty stuff in it like fries
because I'm fat and customers
saw that I made that
and they wanted it but we
couldn't make it for them
because it wasn't actually on the menu.
- You just get creative, you
mix some spicy with some sweet,
some hot with some cold, just
see what you can come up with.
The combinations are endless.
- What's the most annoying
thing you get asked daily?
How many patties are on
a double cheeseburger?
(crickets chirp)
- Ordering on the phone
is annoying because
either you're trying to talk to me
or you're trying to talk
to the other person.
- You know they're from
Canada when they want mayo
for their fries, that's disgusting.
- Be nice to the people
that are making your food.
Got it, one more time for
the people in the back,
be nice to the people
that are making your food
because they're making your food, dude,
like seriously, and
you're not sitting there
watching what they're doing.